[Music]
this looks fantastic mrs. Johnson
yeah and almost looks as good as mom
Stephanie Kerr worked extremely hard on
this oh this I just threw together a
simple recipe this is almost perfect
if only Kyle could have made it home for
Christmas this year
Merry Christmas dad Kyle for the
Christmas miracle
anything for you dad can we go a
different route or something are you
even going down the street this Street
is terrible this time and any
double-time it can we just get a little
faster man I'm kind of late for a flight
right now clearly 15 minutes I'm
stressing out I've never tried to check
through security during the holidays
this is freaking nuts can you turn up
the AC
you remember we can't bring up the Asian
from what Asian base can I say Asian in
my own home so James I had some Thai
food the other day it was to tie for my
dad he's not a racist but he might tell
like a bad joke or two or what
don't worry about I just ignore him dad
I'm Chinese but I do love Thai food we
like Chinese food yes yes yeah maybe you
could cook some pork okay Carol we're
done
don't they all cooked I'm sure Chinese
people cook today's Chinese I think he
doesn't I don't know much about him I
just about him also so alrighty then we
normally do Christmas presents after
dinner but I just can't help myself
[Music]
whoa the new ji phone 6 7 s my gosh
thank you so much daddy I could get this
they're sold out everywhere a magician
never reveals his secrets
I saw it
anything for my kids that Santa
everybody not your brother the big
disappointments Greg yeah Johnny look I
know this has been a hard year for you
it was the divorce and everything I
think for Christmas we're just going to
do our family I hope you understand oh
yeah
Merry Christmas nobody loves Johnny but
everyone loves it
I'm just saying we should give Trump a
chance okay I think it's time to take
our family Christmas picture great idea
yeah family's all here
James skin the picture no no I don't
think James would be in the picture see
that's the fair it is fair this is a
family picture James is not family well
I'm not family yet but I was hoping to
change that today oh gods that will you
marry absolutely not
[Music]
[Music]